you
I am joined alright here we go man
and the Eastern bullet arena at the top
of it
how many 56 have entered first upon an
ace rook speedy the speedy a SREP and
not our first time playing a minor piece
battle as usual let's jump on in I'll
grab some space aina more space
let's give him a kick it's actually
trapped didn't realize that until it
happened that's a full piece oh they
just resign
and I didn't realize it was a full-piece
until uh yeah I just had a count when I
at c5 in I was taking away that
important d6 square no Knight e4 to d6
retreat
Molotov double-oh-seven we're winning
upon ooh
that's helpful
after him I guess now I should have just
developed yeah up a piece and more let's
just trade he's trapped he's a cook
tonight
more trades anything just wanna kill the
night I'll take a pawn first or to flush
the King back
ways to do it running like this the King
is sectioned off no stalemates win and
win fast all right back to tournament we
got a quick two wins 83 I knew there are
going to be more jumping in
okay gotta pace myself here
normally it's the 30 minute tournaments
or 20 called 27 minute tournaments
all right I guess we'll try a/c for a
game try to get in d4
all right we got d4 hmm let's not take
hmm let's take towards the center I have
a central majority so I want to put it
to use castle clean on e2 let's get them
rolling a little bit actually I'm just
dropping upon for what I don't know
fighting my opponent take I don't know
there was an opportunity to take d4
you're writing I don't like how I'm
playing this at all this is no not a
good structure
and I take that night out light square
bishop huh
just back up for a moment this is
serious
so here I get h6 shy down evil on h6 I
want to work towards the light squares
I'll take now I will take with the
bishop defend here I do like though I'm
not sure about that decision okay no the
bishop is sealed off hit the rook
they're just giving me the bishop and I
should just play chief for 9 seconds
making to throw
me too yeah anything like how I play
that opening at all
at all they could have taken on d4 I got
to play a little bit slower in the
beginning
think I'm still in a hyper bullet mode
there still plenty of time here
try a Sicilian
okay don't have too much experience with
this structure
let's try f6 I'm running like this and I
think I would I
I have enough on that right
be careful let's try it now let's try
that centralized knock my bishop back
do this
think he's safer there
I'm on this moon on the this square f4 I
guess we'll continue to play over here
break down the structure now
break it open
Challenge this structure let's jump in
hit its e3 next this is a beautiful
square even if a knight takes them out
cool with that I'm going to take here I
want this square for a night a night
should be really good
upon
could take the discovery this is a good
square as well forks
cut the material back I'm on f4 on the
night twice not getting made at Mi on
the rook discovery checks push Bishop
here oh well that's a killer someone's
going to hurt too many good moves on
that next move
ah killer bees and that one dragon chest
83 let's match that first move can I say
I like this system against white these
these positions with the minors this
right here I'm winning a any pawn we're
coming back over no I'll get to the
seventh rank they want I don't want
to be careful he's unprotected I guess
we'll sneak in a flight square like this
yeah I should I should have went with
that six secure this point could they
have captured that in the previous move
f5 King f7 no ok well it's something
like this back up I'll go here let's go
here
I want to flush that night away let's
double up I could take on b2 just want
to get all my pieces playing them way
down on time now we'll flush him away
step up
some trades
the bishop slowly making progress I like
this structure against against what what
am I trying to say
let's get this majority going whoo it's
very helpful
now
plenty of time take upon ya
could free move this one out
close to it
and just run with the Jeep on that's
right I like this kid my bishop hada any
stalemate ideas I don't want him
controlling any unnecessary squares okay
50 in change I see to12 oh is in there
he's very very fast I'm sure we'll be
getting paired up at some stage plenty
of time I think he just finished from my
beginning pear uptown he just slip up
he drew against a syrup
we're getting paired hanging Chad next
opponents oh I guess III
I guess I can't play Bishop c4 but
alright more conservative with the light
square Bishop let's go here first giving
me the light square bishop
and I got I got some know the Queen
could take forgetting the Queen could
take there okay let's develop I have the
bishop pair I should look to get him
working soon I don't want to see 95 so
let's play d4 94 so let's just play d4
step up with the Queen I could take care
queen is defended yes which is
consolidate this structure kills the
night I'll be sneaking get on this
diagonal it's a good diagonal it's off
for a queen exchange and still be
annoying I think I found a good square
for my queen now g4 just to go here
queen g4 and then we'll return here
maybe now let's do this I don't want to
drop a - I need a flight Square still
yes the Queen's are coming off
here
look out of here rook might end up
getting trapped if not careful that is a
trap truck now
yeah rook has to go here okay
consolidate
just want to get rid of that tricky
night as he trapped the night is trapped
now and then you got down on time
actually back determine we go 47 minutes
and change got 2016 14 13 is where we
stand
okay
x squared' me in the chat
okay we got a Slav no I got juked oh
what's this
sneaky pawn variation alright let's
let's blast it open let's try now let's
try to punish my opponent for that type
of opening we could try try for me
quickest way to make his what now here I
could take on e6 let's go here try for
Queen d2 I'm a Bishop f4 they're opening
it up my opponent is opening it up
I should be getting some materials soon
let's try this I'm keeping me the
scram bishop
ah what am i doing hey let's let's try
this mother up okay
getting some material just want to stop
night see five out I just won the night
was I on that no I wasn't on that knife
for forever
I'm up a rook good slow down a little
bit
hunt down d5 threatened me
maybe right close to me
and they just want the Queen's off throw
a pig on the second seventh they're
being sneaky
I mean a little sneaky there
watch out for this guy vac determined
I'm pretty sure that was a sneaky move
not some mouse slip
okay 45 minutes still
I guess Knight to f6 and c5
okay let's go punch up v2 it's not a fun
move to play b3 there is at some stage
Bishop e3 I mean you might lose control
over the C file
I'll take with the pun they take my
night and then break down at their
Center take once hit at d4 again
something better I don't think so
take with the bishop
keep the tension put a rock on c8 which
rook I don't know probably the F Rock
there's a new home for my pieces
all right let's let's trade now take
with the bishop let's get rid of him
he's too good keep the tension for one
move and let's let's still keep the
tension I want to double up and then
timely capture I'm ready to win peace I
want the Queen's on actually I like I
could have taken with the Queen and want
some material let's go like this and
this is taking advantage of the pin and
I should have I should have done
something different there
okay
in here ah where are we out here how's
the material yes we centralized
get in a better flight square I just
want to burn some clock is all burn the
clock
they're not going to have any time
I should have had something different
there I should have been able to take
advantage that pin on the C file
okay yeah should have been able to do
something different there
okay what can you do you know
I probably should have traded Queens
because after that I don't think I don't
see how they defend the sea pond guys
playing so fast i winning upon
hmm I don't wanna
I don't know how good that double pawn
is
let's just centralized some baby moves
contest a file square for my king I want
both rooks off it seems like both trucks
are gonna come off joke it made it their
nightmare as my knight moves
I guess we're gonna have everything come
off soon bishops gonna get flushed back
no no I'll go pawn grabbing I'm on g4 at
the end of it they could get d5 I get g4
yeah I get upon
something good here let's just throw
punches go after f5 that was tempting as
well okay where are the forks
III Queen here Knight g3 how about I
just pushed this guy
I got one of these two night hits out
light squares and I just run with him
okay that concerns me a little bit
let's get a new square
right here defend f7 okay they're down
on time
all right 20 minutes Organa there are a
hundred and sixty-four in here okay
Agustin
let's try Nene for a game French defense
tirage Oh we'll go at an exchange see if
I could hunt down their queen okay they
wasted some time they're normally try to
preserve okay maybe queenside castle
would have been a better idea little
uncomfortable isn't it try and stick my
queen on c6 pressure on c7 now they get
c2 at the end I want to take with the
Queen I'll just go here c5 I could take
on the Queen and I just take another
pawn it's thinking about taking the
night for what reason I don't know no
reason to take the knight their weakness
here
I'll up on e6 just backup
and I'm winning stuff now and winning
more stuff I'm on the bishop and the
rook
and this night is a gonner hangout these
squares covered rook takes pawn next and
it's clean from here run for a touchdown
plenty of time back to terman
all right we got 36 36 29 25 that was
the second place guy
that a Taejo opponent I think they
paused you know he paused it's not in
there anymore okay I don't know some
some different set up I guess they're
gone Queen side stop Knight b5 I haven't
committed my king over here I might I
might go Queen side let's focus on some
development before I go in for this its
castle could take the bishop with check
if I want it also take here first and
see anything wrong with that hitting the
Queen I'm on the rook I don't want the
rook I do want this though let me let me
make sure I could get the dark square
Bishop first now I'll take the Rucker
because if Queen takes I get this let's
run it like this here and then Queen
here there is a bishop in a queen check
this should be crushing though now I'm
getting the Queen pawn takes I had Queen
d5 forking the rook in the pawn main
threat and that's the other main
okay
a fast paring Tavo 86
let's try d4 game Budapest gambit oh I'm
almost always cool with just giving the
pawn right back yeah uh I miss play this
once this position so many times I want
to put my knight on d5 and I guess we're
gonna get some exchanges here huh I want
to get this bishop playing
it's taking me forever to do this though
I just dropped c4 hey I gotta find
something different oh I didn't want to
do that
how's a mouse slip let's try it again
let's get my bishop on B to my opponents
going for my throat by the way from my
knight on f4 f5 even better Queen
exchange okay now they're in a pin I go
here should be able to win stuff let's
just develop though with this rock I
want to keep him defended d6 is just
difficult to defend isn't it Oh take
once let's play against their isolated
pawn let's get out of a knight move wits
check now we'll go here and one more I
have a fancy night let's try this now I
don't know why I'm playing it like this
why am I
getting out of a pen
and I go for fancy time burners
huh
holy cow don't repeat that kind of play
ever ah man that was an ugly game ugly
opening ugly middle game and then a
clueless and absolutely clueless end
game Wow
don't take any notes from that game any
of you with the pen and paper out throw
that paper away why was that horrible
awful all right let's see how they feel
about a pin let's see how they feel it's
hit the pinned pawn and develop like a
champion like a champ
oh I'll dive right in there let's
develop bishops short on Squares isn't
he isn't he
let's cover some squares let's get all
my pieces playing my Knights control all
four Center squares I like that I need a
flight square we got the flight square
watch out g5 might hit one day oh don't
forget about this either you know this
this this right here what I was thinking
about oh look at the fanciness ooh
they resigned if I took here there's
Queen takes Knight I had that I have
Queen takes Knight okay no I was gonna
say from the second titled arena when in
the first first game that I was
commenting on Caruana versus uh penguin
mr. Andrew tank he trapped that Bishop
like that so I was thinking about that
in that game for a second so I learned
from the penguin is what I'm saying
penguin helped me win that game win that
piece all right what's my queen doing
over here is better throw a punch at the
Queen side okay I just covered this this
is this is the first world chess
championship game sort of this kind of
break
and centralized what to do I'm on f2
check like this
I want another flight square
ah hoo boy I should have moved a long
time ago that would took way too long
what I just did there I think that's a
safe pre move another safe one and I put
a dent in their structure yes
can I give me no but they should be a
little bit scared now just a little bit
on c5 let's cover everything clean is
covering everything
sneaky rook g5 down on time
where's the main I afford a coin
exchange I could on this another pin
okay they're gonna give some checks okay
I'll get another phone
oh and it's a draw
time tho sneaky move
a good shot
yeah for sure that
a good shot
on King and pawn in-game where we are at
the halfway point 195 are in here turkey
chili is the opponent all right turkey
chili not our first time turkey chili
has some wheels I know this see if I
could get him to budge
can I take care was this some Theory by
getting hit with some theory seem just
like not them I'm up upon ur right you
in a second
that's just defend
[Music]
okay uh what do I do here huh
let's preserve these guys
Oh in exchange I am definitely cool with
Queens off the board I don't fear my
king position and you now we look to
break down this structure I'll take with
the pawn he is enormous I want to get
one rook off and I'm getting a second
pawn
it should be a pretty clean King and
pawn in game or rook rook and pawn in
game uh let's hang onto him for a moment
improve my king they meant to go here
numb I'm winning out another pond rooks
off and King and pawn and game is
easy
the king is not necessary in this
endgame
and nine seconds is enough
anytime now stalemates
now stalemates back to Terman okay we're
out 56 56 40 34 28 in change 200 on the
nose 201 now dr. Scully has a late join
okay we'll try an e for game
in Carroll Khan huh let's try in advance
and so we're going to support the center
mmm let's put the night here and here
let's challenge him immediately I want
him to do something soon ooh going like
that let's break it open over here now I
changed my mind
okay words it's going to turn queenside
now
should have done something over here
sooner okay something should happen over
here I'm taking with the pond I want
something happening here okay oh they
could take that pun got lucky
it's just double out
f7 I'll take this pawn first feel like
they need to sacrifice somehow let's
double up let's go here in case they try
to take that pawn up
pawn hunting okay night is gonna hunt
down this pawn the rook is nearly
trapped the rook is trapped
I don't wanna he's trapped
all their pieces are trapped there nine
is trapped the rook is trapped I'll take
him now
the night is still dead hit him twice
and he can't be defended
right in the corner only has two squares
and they were its neural stalemates they
resign sixty forty thirty eight is where
we are at
26 minutes to go 208 now let's see who
we get next ask chess all right a
Sicilian and then what's hmm the winged
gambit huh
[Music]
to play d5 and reply to that move so now
it's like French
I guess I'll take
I have to be careful in my dark squares
I'll just let them do it like this oh
they're allowing me to castle I got to
do this quick
be timely there's 96 I go here defend
this pawn and then challenge this night
as soon as possible maybe a better
approach was to defend this pawn with
the Queen so I could go from point A to
point B recapturing on CA I just want to
get into c4 stop f5 for the moment okay
I'm spending weight oh my God look at my
time swamp that Queens off - get over
here fast along the Queen's come off but
I am I am in some trouble here for sure
that night is so dangerous so dangerous
just wanna mouth okay let's hang
on him eight seconds
I have that defended wine I take that
pond five seconds
you
I caught up on the clock no that's a bad
pre-move not sure how I caught up on the
clock
okay fought back on that one I was deep
in the think tank and at one point in
that one dr. Scully
opponent should be an excellent position
for me just want to reposition my knight
to this square and this should be
winning
actually they takes b7 I don't want that
pawn I want a six a six should be
falling jump in how they complete
development
oh I going too fast there yeah I think
they were anticipating Bishop takes a
six there but just in general that that
structure I think is close to winning
out of the opening having the open a
file and that timely pressure against b7
the night reposition there aints so
Sicilian
let's try quick b5 c7 okay we're going
to take
ship takes that's different so no night
move all right I could do this right
maybe I should have done that moment one
move sooner so I'm getting Eve for my
not
let's take with the bishop I have these
squares covered Queen c6 could be
difficult to me let's defend the night
with the pawn ha dropping here they
don't want that my castle
I have enough control for this that
scares me
defending and throwing a punch I also
have this move I still have this move
maybe and I do night here that scares me
a little bit what's that move about
yikes should have thought a little bit
more okay now I could get the Queen's
off there's a pin no main threat Knight
takes I take with the Queen
I'll tell you this I have this square
covered I'm just up a full piece two
three yeah I think that's a full piece
most fast pairing twenty minutes to go
all righty we're gonna take first Knight
f3 next and only then he for valuable
time I have some space and I have a time
edge development edge I should say uh
now will take only after the bishop has
moved okay so how are they getting the
pawn back how they pull that off
let's run it like this oh I think you
win the phone
that's how they get the pawn back okay
Oh Knight here I could take and then win
the bishop he's out of play after this I
do not like how I'm playing this
position okay and get into d6 this is
the way forward
d 6 r b6 r d 5 let's get into d5 that's
a sensitive point now let's get off to
get the light squared bishop off
challenge this knight he's too good he's
too good he's too good
ninety-five soon let's keep it closed
he's a dangerous pawn that's helpful I
needed to sort this out let's take like
that and you know what let's hunt him
down or at least attempt to first my
bishop in play now why did I take the
pawn I don't know stop Knight here
the night out of there let's try this
see what happens on this with check
why'd I do that
that was silly and I got a time burn
whoo
hello I want to just hide my king
and I hide my king it's easy to preme of
this they are being sneaky there
time oh man
okay why does it have to be like that I
was struggling to find a plane in that
middle game very clumsy play okay I
played this earlier let's just go here
and I guess we take and develop mm-hmm
let's put the Queen on G it's free
bishop here Rick on d1 what's that Queen
donor let's try to get C foreign c4 next
hmm let's try c4 right now bishop in
Queens scare me let's let's shoo them
away should have taken the night let's
let's take the night now support my
Center have anything fancy against the
queen she is unprotected two bishops
versus two Knights move let's go back
okay my queen has a job I don't like
that
my queen still has a job don't oh and ah
there's Queen here
I have to I have to go here I think my
queen needs to be freed up
defending what my queen
let's go here oh boy that's ugly it's
definitely an ugly move to do oh I just
dropped my queen I didn't take it they
didn't take my queen oh man a blunder up
back-to-back err 16 and change to 26 are
in here 8050 4442 alright who do we get
next to 26
dr. Scully a stroke a stroke it is
alright
no let's try this
we've been here before ace
okay I'm going to break or thief or
probably break soon a thief or or not
move later clean needs to flee that a
mouse
let's sneak in a flight squirrel hmm
what are they doing with that
let's play over here just a little bit
put a dent in the structure I was trying
to put a dent in the structure that
night is too good they have a nice dark
square control let's get rid of him
h3 let's go with h3 that night is so
good the night is very good very good
night how do I get rid of him to get in
c5
tough to suggest something here
the light-square bishop off not allowing
it
you
get on this square
light-square control
first
and I'd be a rat race
you
Oh
you
sneaky there oh man I was just clicking
like a maniac so fast man
and another pairing oh boy
okay e4 e5 gamma this is different I
don't play this so much okay he's he's a
tough guy let's get rid of him
dark square bishop both bishops gun
let's play in the F file Kings side is
where I want to be f5 is where I want to
be Knights he's a tough cookie I should
have jumped in first before Rock f2 I
think he needs to get out of there oh
and actually that works out because if
he moved I had Knight takes pawn yes
we're gonna win upon it sticker rook
right here yeah I guess we're gonna have
an exchange so uh uh where's my knight
belong got to sort that out fast this is
not the way - not the way to do it
my knight needs to play and he's not
playing oh boy
oh I wasted so much time just then my
knight should be on g3
oh yes did a lot of time my King needs
to come back over I know what I want to
do now but I just wasted way too much
time rook here I should have done now
rook here now got the rooks off don't
give up a pond don't give up a pond fix
their pawns on light squares if you can
how can we pull this off ooh
I didn't see that idea I need a dark
square blockade
no I can't let you take him not sure
what that was about
I really have anything good here
okay now maybe I want my knight right
here
you
holy cow they only needed one more
moving it was a draw my pond stuck
around I want on time
Oh
that cost me so much time when did the
queens were off I just for some reason I
couldn't assess what I was supposed to
do fast enough eventually I figured out
something but ah too much
too much time invested I'm okay with
double pawns
put the bishop here the knight wants to
be there
in fact we'll go here now castle rook c8
for Team white okay now we'll take and
then we'll jump in what I like this I'll
take and
challenge taketake queen d5 it's running
like this maybe I should have captured
here first
actually I'm winning upon now in Bishop
III I have a fork okay it's nice to have
time let's put a rook on the seventh
second
and flight square
scout here they can't they can't take
with the rook they get made it forgot
about that
back to chairman nine minutes to go
now 9262 48
to 35 to 36 in here all right all right
I
plenty of experience with this setup
were basically a move ahead this is what
was just played in the last game wasn't
it where I'm a move ahead because this
uh there's a piece that moved a second
time I'll take with the knight back him
up and then get to this square right now
going with the night so I could flush
him away before he gives me a problem
focus on the e4 square even a queen here
is very good and if the Queens are off
and they are now I have the better
Bishop because of the earlier decisions
play g5 probably should have played g4
yeah but this is still good because I
have this with the tempo my king is even
going to have some fun on the e4 square
he's flushed away my king wants to be a
fighter efore is where he will love to
be let's break with the B form not just
yet can we improve think we can improve
let's centralize the King and then do
this and I want their King to get to
this Square too easily I could do this
because then there's a pin and I could
get a queen so one piece off let's hang
on to him and now I'm kind of stuck
actually let's try this they take their
in a pin and this is a one King and pawn
in game I think no it's not actually
gonna have a draw you know we're gonna
have a draw actually they had a win they
could do this I had something better I
know I must have had something better
there I probably shouldn't have pushed
the pawn anyhow back to tournament 94
62-52 yeah I had something better there
hmm so close all right see for ya head
control over them their g4 move I
probably should have prevented g4
get in this move okay this is a very
close position let's try this now that
the night hasn't played to have six hmm
annoying pin let's close it
I'm in trouble
I think have to do this and I'm just
barely getting away with the night - H -
I'll look what I found move that's all
that is
I could Castle queenside
they have that move hmm I'll take with
the night and try to show that he's a
monster and he is a monster mm-hmm
they should be painful let's try an Ag
for now I'll take this even a night here
could be pretty good let's take care in
return that pond is a great thorn so is
this guy right here probably feeling the
pressure of a the h3 pond okay with
tucking Mike hanging over here let's do
this oh I'm on the rook
could take their they get made it if
they take me to ten seconds to go and
they resign back determine 96 all right
less than five this went by fast Adam
air Adam era I thought earlier in the
stream you were saying you were going to
bed
shouldn't you be in bed now in some some
fifty five minutes later here you are
okay yeah de mer I don't know what to
think now I don't know if I could trust
you anymore I thought we had something I
could get it b5 looks unprotected and
[Music]
take once not twice though I need to get
in some more development King here was
the way to do that actually this should
have been his home
I got ba covered that should be a great
bother and I could play this taking
advantage of another pin eroding there's
no way for I got that covered so we're
gonna take with the rook and welcome
some more exchanges so I got some space
I'm gonna have a pawn all rooks off I
still have BA covered they missed that
he's an he's a knife akka knife 98 three
and change I guess just one more is
gonna count for the tournament - if
you're lucky let's see - 44 in here
Zen chess again Zen chest was a man I
I've had nine lives in this tournament
nine lives
okay let's let's throw a punch
not sure how to organize my pieces
really not sure okay I guess starting
with a night here is okay
I don't know where I want to go with my
king
back up
before and I gotta take that
okay so now maybe I put some pressure on
the light squares what's he doing
I cancelled there yet I try to make me
on h7 in a sack here my knight needs
some help
he's a bad piece where does he belong
after the light square bishop sir
exchanged probably c6 oh why didn't I
see that that's a mouth is this crazy
I'm gonna try it my Kings gonna try to
find shelter over here let's go here I'm
in trouble again oh oh I'm on the night
how long have I been on the night
how long was I on that night I have a
check down on time I'm gonna drop my
queen again
I'm on the rook I was on the rook get
the Queen's after they see that they're
in check they might miss that traveler
Queen
Oh My gods in chess so close again okay
102 62 - 45 50 seconds left this one
will not be counting for the tournament
unless we try scholars mate tactics
we'll try fishing pole for the last one
it's not gonna happen
the anti-phishing Paul II for f4 what's
that move about definitely much more
inclined to play knight c6 when a4 is
there because of this move let's go for
a fiend cut oh this is what I should
have been doing in those other games
this is the system connect the Knights
keep my F pawn free stop any G for ID I
give this square up I'll take like this
I want a square for my bishop
he's a dummy let's close it up close it
down
that's the tournament clock triple zeros
what's he doing he needs to do something
else and I guess we're gonna shoot for
b5 I don't want to castle
Castle I'm going to Castle by hand
fancy happening here my rook is there to
defend put the rook up actually I want
one rip off these guys are scaring me
get one rook off one rook off is all I
want
and all the entry points are covered
can work off I'm just gonna play with
these three pieces my bishop can't I
don't really see what his future is also
way down on time spend the night sneak
in with the Queen just don't get made it
in you're golden
any other down on time
okay back to tournament 102 62 5653 is
where we stand myself dr. Scully
hey snook my gosh 1983 and many others
pretty good turnout nearly 250 in that
one let's see all the pages
there are many
Eastern bullet arena packs a a pretty
big crowd let's see all the participants
yeah so many so many close calls in that
one probably should have had a good for
a good four losses from this tournament
yeah definitely not squeaky clean
okay to the 245 of you good games Oh
you